Wow. How many people do you think
worldwide are working in your field?
Uh, so in terms of leading
labs, there's about 20,
30 broadly.
There's a probably a few hundred labs
and other all in essentially the same
field of study.
They're all working with the same
molecules in the same parameters. Uh, no.
Um,
that not everyone works with molecules.
But what I can tell you is we get
together in conferences and we talk about
discovering new gene that extends lifespan
and a new molecule that's working in
mice or sometimes in humans, but
it's a big field now. It's grown.
And when I started it was the backwater
of biology, antioxidants, et cetera.
I was very lucky to start when it was
really small and stick it out of those
fair amount of criticism in those
days. What, how so like that,
it was like a lot of my friends,
my supervisor said I was insane for
working on aging. That's not a thing.
That's not biology really. Yeah.
Wow. Wait, how long ago was this? Uh,
so I came to the u s from
Sydney in 1995 went to MIT.
And the scientists in the lab that
I joined, Lenny guarantee's lab,
they two students had just started
working to figure out why yeast get old.
And I joined as the third senior person
to join and all the other people in,
in the lab, there are about 18, 19
people. They said, you are nuts,
Len. He's lost his mind. He's
working on aging. That's not a thing.
You should be working on what we do,
which is understanding how
genes are regulated. So I
called up my mom and I said,
I think I've made a big mistake here.
I thought this was the thing and the
guy and everyone here says he's nuts.
Meanwhile, you were right. Well,
you gotta take some risks in life.
That's one lesson. Yeah, but
that's an interesting one, right?
Because you were a young fellow.
He didn't really totally know.
It was pretty lucky because
I'm in Australia, right?
I don't know what people are saying
about this lab shorter there. Uh,
but always been fascinated with aging
since I was four. Well now though,
with all the promising new discoveries,
I mean they,
they have to be eating crow as it were.
Talk to those people. I go,
hey, fuck face. I was right. No,
you don't call them up in the
middle of the night drunk. No,
I definitely forgive people too much.
Had some pretty big enemies along the way,
but I try to be nice.
Is it because a research and this sort
of scientific work is so competitive?
Yeah, it is. It is. And there's
this belief that someone's
success is your failure.
It's not really that that is the case,
but exist in show business too.
It's a weird sort of a mindset.
It's a very limiting mindset.
Right. And also, and this may be
true in Hollywood, in science,
if you come up with a new idea,
when you're young,
you're young Turk and you're
upsetting the status quo.
I know that Thomas Kuhn's book
on structure of scientific
revolutions was just
had it had it, right. He wrote it in
the 60s about chemistry and physics,
but it applies to biology that if can't,
with a new theory that's at disruptive,
the current leaders will attack you and
it's a period of chaos and you just have
to get through it.
And fortunately I'd read Kuhn's book
and I knew that this was normal,
but a lot of people around
me were saying, oh no, what?
People are saying we're
wrong and it's controversial.
We don't want to be controversial.
I'm like, controversies, great, let's,
let's do more of that. And if it's not
controversial, I don't want to do it.
That is interesting.
Do you think that's because the
people who are the old guard or upset,
they didn't fight it themselves or they
upset that your new findings will make
their work look irrelevant? Yes.
It's probably a bit of both,
but mostly it's, it's that they're
worried that their lives will be, have,
have been in vain if what they're working
on is not true. Right. Yeah. There's a,
there's an amazing documentary on the
Sphinx where these geologists are talking
about some of the, uh, water or
erosion outside the area of the Sphinx.
And they're saying this points to the
fact that construction was thousands of
years older than they thought. And you
see this one egyptologist freaking out.
He's freaking out.
Like what evidence,
what evidence of this culture
you're talking about? Like,
cause apparently it would have
predated the known dates of 2,500 BC,
but if it made it like
7,000 years old in that,
because it would have to be back when
there was rainfall in the Nile Valley and
you could see this guy's ego kicking
him because he had, he was a professor,
he had been teaching Egyptology and he
was freaking out instead of examining
this evidence,
like Whoa,
like talking to this geologist who
studies rocks and erosion is who is really
steadfast, is a Boston
university geologist, a doctor
Robert Shock. And you know,
he's saying this is evidence of water
erosion. And he's like showing it.
And he even showed it to a bunch of
other geologists and they all agreed,
and this guy, this egyptologist and this
documentary was freaking out. I was like,
wow, that's what happens when you think
your whole life's work is horseshit. Yeah.
It can be a blow to the ego. Um,
I haven't lived through that yet.
It's probably coming.
But uh,
what I've noticed is that the really
successful scientists and people in life
just embrace change. And you know,
that kind of have to, I mean,
it doesn't mean that that guy is a loser.
It just means he was acting on incorrect
information based on what they knew
before. I mean, it should
embrace it and say, look,
we know certain things
were built at 2,500 BC,
like the great pyramid that's
been pretty clearly established,
but it looks like there was some ancient
structures that were there even before
then.
Let's now we have new things to study.
They don't look at it that way though.
Yeah.
Say the problem with with how biology
and actually most facts are taught, uh,
theories that taught is that,
uh,
there's a textbook and that's
the Bible equivalent. Uh,
what I try to teach my students is can
you please just forget everything you've
just learned.
And what's important to know is that
most things we think we know are not
correct. They're going to
change over time. All theories
change. Newton was wrong,
but he helped us get here,
uh, expect that we only know,
you know, 0.01% of, of
what we need to figure out.
And a lot of what we think
we know is wrong anyway.
So even if you have the greatest theory,
expect that it will be overturned,
but you can at least cherish the fact
that you've helped us get to that point.
Because without Newton, we wouldn't
have quantum physics. Well,
for someone like me, hearing you say
that, it's very promising and it's, it's,
it's very encouraging.
But I always thought that scientists
were always going on just data.
Like the, all they cared about was data.
All they cared about is what is correct.
And that was what was crucial.
That's what's important.
This is what they talk about.
This is what this study,
when I found out that scientists would,
would ignore information or use their own
personal biases against information or
attack research because it somehow
negates what they've done is very
disheartening for someone who's
not a scientist. And you go, oh no,
the egos in science too.
Right. It's disheartening. As
a scientist, I can tell it.
There were,
there was a time of great change in the
aging field where we discovered genes
control aging and molecules like
whereas virtual could extend health and
lifespan. It was, it was brutal. You,
I'd get up and give a speech and someone
to say, you're wrong. This is crap.
And where are they now? Do you call
them up in the middle of the night? Uh,
they still owe him up. You've
done all little fuckers, right?
I have a couple of glass of wine.
Yeah.
Well I think the secret to success in
life is actually just existing for long
enough and all your enemies
to fall away while they die.
They're not into anti-aging. Yeah. That
looks like shit and I can't walk anymore.
Just have to outlive your
enemies. Yeah. That's an easy way.
That must have been a tough time though,
for you as a young man. And you know,
you're,
you're hearing this from these established
scientists and part of you must've
been like thinking like,
Jeez, are they right? Sure.
You have to entertain the possibility
that you're wrong, that that's what we do.
Uh, but you go back to the
lab and you'd retest it.
So I went through a really brutal
period in my career where we had data,
we interpreted it,
we published it in the top journals,
and it was about how rich
virtual works on that,
sir to an enzyme that I
mentioned. And Pfizer, um,
came out with a paper
that said it's all wrong.
And I had people call me up saying,
you know, it was nice knowing you.
I'm really sad for you, but it's over.
Yeah. Bad. That set book. I look,
uh, and so I went back to the lab. We
had some data already from years before,
which I knew were interesting and it
took another four years to get to the
bottom of it.
But it turns out in the end I was right,
but there were days when
I said, screw humanity. I,
I can't even be bothered getting out
of bed if this is how I'm going to be
traded for trying to devote my life
to the betterment of people's lives.
It's tough.
Um,
now I think anybody who's in a position
in their career like that has to have
gone through really hard times.
It's just discouraging from a non
scientist who relies on people like you.
For someone like me who relies on the
folks like you out there doing the hard
work that you would face,
that sort of, I mean,
I guess the best way to describe
it would be ignorance. Well, it,
it's okay for scientists
to challenge a theory.
That's what I didn't know what
everybody is trained to do. Uh,
but to do it in such a public end and
Vish, controversial, it was vicious.
It was definitely vicious. Even the
words they used were vicious. Uh,
which is really hurtful,
but, but they're wrong.
Well they might've been right or wrong.
Call him up.
Melonite you dumb motherfucker. Yeah.
The person who published that paper,
I do think about meeting
that person again. Uh,
but they do and destroyed careers.
It's not just, it's tough.
You can run out of money is students
go away. That was happening to my lab.
We went down to four people. I mean, and
what was the high, uh, I mean these days.
Um, but what we were before then, it was
about 18, 20. And you went down to four.
Four. So it was looking bad. Oh yeah.
People had written me off. Holy Shit.
But you were right when he
got to push forward, it's uh,
you got to get lane cause you're not going
to get government funding for a while.
Cause people think that you're, you're
a failure. God Damn, that's crazy.
Well, sciences is not for the faint of
heart, I would imagine. Yeah. Boy Skin,
thick skin. A stubbornness
only. Only those survive.
Right. What was the turnaround like?
Was there a moment where it turned
around and moved into your favor? Yeah,
there was, there was one day when it, when
it all changed. So the, the earlier data,
so we're data driven, nearly data
was that the enzyme, um, we can,
we can mutate or change the enzyme so
that it wasn't going to be activated by
reserve trial.
And we found that mutation now that just
technically on non tickling technically
means that we could, uh, change the
enzyme in a way it wouldn't work.
So we then put that nonworking enzyme
into a cell and now we have a mouse that
doesn't work and give it
resveratrol. And if it, if it works,
it means I'm wrong.
If it doesn't work and it's blocked
by that change in the enzyme,
we're probably right. And that's
what we did. But the real,
the real change was that there was a
company that I started that was making
drugs, the one that, uh, cured or
at least seem to cure psoriasis.
Uh, and they had made these very synthetic
molecules that were not related to the
plant molecules is virtual.
And so I said to myself and to
the student who was working on it,
the very brave student,
if,
if the change in that
enzyme also blocks the drug,
they were onto something because that
means two separate groups working on
separate types of molecules,
different people,
different systems, all get blocked by
this one little change in the enzyme,
then we're right. And, and so he walked
over to the company, he got the molecule,
throw it on the enzyme and
it didn't work on the mutant.
And that was me,
uh,
rejoicing because I could say there was
a universal activation mechanism on this
one enzyme. There's virtual works, ah,
the molecules at the company work.
And now there's an interesting thing
that just came out from Spain that
Metformin,
the diabetes drug may actually work the
same way as these other molecules by
activating our favorite
enzyme, the Sirtuin. Wow.
And how,
how much time were you in the dark lands?
It was a couple of years
of hell. Yeah, right.
If it gets so bad because you've got this
tight knit group of scientists and you
have lab meetings and you present
your results and usually you're very
supportive trying to help.
I had one guy saying to my student,
David doesn't know what he's talking
about. You shouldn't work on this.
It's been proven wrong.
He was dead against me in my own lab and
paying his salary and it's okay to be
constructive but vicious within my
own group. Well, suffice to say,
he wasn't in my grief for that long.
Wow.
Now this other guy that used all
these other vicious words about you,
where's he at now? Not sure
I would know. I would know.
Now I turn a time out to look back. I'm
looking forward. You're nicer than me.
Yeah.
You know what?
I'm in science because it's very
collaborative and you're often,
your enemies are reviewing your own work.
Uh, if you build up too many enemies,
you weren't survives. It's definitely
healthier approach. I'm sharing.
I probably would do exactly what you did,
but it still has gotta be beautiful to
come out on the other end and be proven.
Correct. And actually be at the forefront
of these emerging technologies. Uh,
well it, it, it is a minute, not
rest on any laurels, but the,
what I do is I pause and I remember
how hard it was to get here and how
fortunate I am to have made it this far.
And I'm working with hundreds
of collaborators around
the world to make this
come true. This idea that we can really
treat aging and prevent deterioration.
So I'm blessed. I have an APP on my phone
that I've helped engineer. What's that?
Uh, it's called Louis Lea. And
where's that? Uh, well, it's, uh,
it's a little company that
we bought in New York and uh,
nurses and dentists use it to
pass medical information around,
but we use it to share information
between scientists around the world and
coordinate activities between
companies that are started. Yeah.
So, you know, I think I mentioned to
you that I've started a few companies.
What I'm trying to build our companies
that are the 21st century version of a
Pharma company that is actually has
a decent reputation in the world.
I think it's pharmaceutical companies,
whether it's deserved or
not have a pretty bad rap.
I'm trying not to fall into that trap,
but I'm also trying to use 21st
secretary technology to not become too
bureaucratic as well within
the organization. That's
what the Luma App offers us.